Modify onCreate to create
the LocationEntry database table using
the constants we defined
in the contract.
The good news is that
this is a similar but
simpler statement than what
we have in WeatherEntry.
You'll be creating and executing
a string that stores an SQLI command.
You want to make sure to use
the correct data types for each column.
Also, make sure that you
have the right constraints.
In general, for
all the model of the weather table.
With the exception of the ID,
all columns must be defined as not null.
The location query should
additionally be defined as unique or
coordinates are real, or
floating point values.
You should consider adding logging
statements to print the SQLI statement,
and verify that it
looks as you intended.
Pay close attention to spaces,
parenthesis, and commas.
Once you have finished writing
the SQL to create the table,
continue to run test create TestcreateDB
from within the test DB, and
let it guide you as to how to
fix your creation statement.
Once you have finished coding,
I recommend looking at our solution,
just in case our test missed something.